>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
Thank you for coming.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb, Chief of the
African and Middle Eastern Division
and I'm delighted to welcome you in
our reading room for what promises
to be a very exciting film.
We're going into children's
books today.
But before we go any further, and
I do this for all our programs,
I say something about our division.
We're a division that's made up
of three sections: the African,
the Near East, and
the Hebraic sections.
We cover -- We're responsible
for the collections
from 78 different countries
in their vernacular that is
in the languages of those countries.
We collect in all fields
except for clinical medicine
because there is a national
library of medicine.
We don't collect also in the
technical aspects of agriculture
because we have a library
of agriculture.
But with few exceptions,
we collect in every field,
from every direction, every way.
And our reading rooms are places
where readers come to be served.
They sit and we bring them the books
that they can use to
do their research.
But this division, like the others
and like the Library of Congress
in general, is not just a place
where books are put on shelves,
where we just buy them and
hoard them, so to speak.
We want to share them and to
share more than simply the books.
We want to share also the knowledge
of the cultures, the societies,
and the people who produce those
books, to share their ideas,
to share their culture,
their values, their art,
and their contribution
to world civilization.
And so we invite speakers, we
invite filmmakers, we invite poets,
we invite historians, social
scientists who have done research,
some of whom have used
our collections,
some who have used other
collections, to come and talk
about the books, the research,
the people of these societies.
We do exhibits as well.
And relevant to these exhibits
is the Persian Book Exhibit
that we had a couple of years ago.
And that was a remarkable
exhibit, the first of its kind.
It was called A Thousand
Years of the Persian Book.
And we had the Persian book
specialist here, Hirad Dinavari,
who contributed in the
selection of the books.
We have Fatemeh Keshavarz from the
University of Maryland who brought
in her knowledge and
her knowhow to help
with putting this exhibit together.
We had many parts of the
library that came together
from the digital part of the
library, to preservation,
to the exhibit part,
all came together.
Over ten divisions in
this library contributed
to putting together this
exhibit on the Persian book.
But the exhibit is also part
of the type of thing that we do
that is sharing with the
world the civilization,
the culture of the
societies that we represent.
So the exhibit was then
followed by a lecture series,
a series with experts who came and
in collaboration with the University
of Maryland under Fatemeh
Keshavarz's guidance,
we brought in a number of speakers
and had, well it went up to what,
14 presentations over
the period of six months
that talked about the Persian book.
So we had the exhibit and then
we also had the series of talks.
And it was so successful that we
decided we really should continue
with this series of books and with
the series on Persian civilization,
culture, history, and
the production of books.
And so we did.
So last year we had a
number of speakers who spoke
about Persian philosophy.
And this year we're also
doing arts, literature, films.
So the program you're going to be
seeing today is part of that series.
I will not go into it
because we have Fatemeh here
who will describe this program, but
it is a continuation of what started
with the Persian Book
Exhibit and in partnership
with the University of Maryland.
So I'm really excited.
I haven't seen the film.
We have the son of the children's
books writer Mr. Yamini Sharif
who is here with his family.
I would like to recognize
them all here
because it's exciting [applause]
to have not only a film,
the producer of the film, and the
family and the descendents of those
of that family who has worked
on those children's books.
And now without further ado,
I'd like to introduce
Professor Fatemeh Keshavarz
who will be addressing and
talking about the program.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz: Thank
you so much, Mary-Jane.
It's been a pleasure and
honor really with working
with friends here at the Library
of Congress, Hirad, Mary-Jane,
and others who have been giving
us this wonderful opportunity
to bring moments from the
Persian culture and literature
and art to a much bigger public.
I remember we were taking
numbers down and saw
that in the first series we had
over 700 people coming to this room
to listen to those things.
So that's just wonderful.
And we are going on with this
and we're going to have the focus
on film and performance, so we will
have this year many other experts
to be talking about literature,
Persian literature as it comes
to life either on stage or through
illustrations and visual beauty
that represents the
art and the culture.
Again, I'm not going to say
a whole lot about the film
because you're going to see it.
Let me just say we've been
trying to do this for over a year
and I'm absolutely delighted that
we finally are able to do this.
And let me just tell you
that as I grew up in Iran,
just seeing even before I
could really read properly,
when I saw the name Yamini Sharif,
I knew that a beautiful poem,
a beautiful song was coming because
my parents would read it to me.
Later on, of course,
in school, we had it.
We had it all.
So for me, he was the representation
of a kind of art and beauty
that was accessible to me,
but at the same time was
really at the highest level.
So he had this ability to bring
this complicated and complex art
of poetry writing to
children which is tremendous.
He did a lot more.
The film is going to talk
about establishing a school,
doing his own childhood education,
establishing the first magazine,
but I'm not going to
duplicate that information.
But it's tremendously
happy occasion for us
to have Mr. Homan Yamini
Sharif and family here with us.
And what a wonderful
thing that he produced,
even though his own training, I
shouldn't maybe say "even though,"
his own training is in engineering,
but like many other people coming
from engineering or
medical backgrounds,
he has a tremendous
interest in Persian art.
And obviously he grew
up in a household
in which this poetry was celebrated.
So what a wonderful thing that he
produced children's songwriter,
this documentary that we are going
to see and we are going to also
from now on make it available
to our Persian classes,
to be able to actually
learn about him.
So Mr. Yamini Sharif,
Homan Yamini Sharif,
established a children's book, I'm
sorry, the Yamini Sharif Foundation,
which works with the
Children's Book Council of Iran,
so it's a very interconnected,
interdisciplinary enterprise
in which still the interest in
education of the children is
at the forefront of their ideas.
So without further ado,
I'm going to welcome them.
And I don't know if you're saying
anything about the film beforehand,
but I know you're discussing
it afterwards,
but it's really entirely up to you.
[ Inaudible Audience Comment ]
Okay, so Mr. Homan Yamini Sharif,
please welcome him to the podium.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Homan Yamini Sharif: Thank you
very much for coming here today
to watch this documentary together.
I'd like to thank the people that
made this possible, this event,
which is really an honor for us to
be here in the Library of Congress.
Dr. Keshavarz from Roshan
Institute, University of Maryland,
and Dr. [inaudible] who
from last year followed up
and supported us in
making this possible.
I'd like to thank the Library
of Congress, Mrs. Mary-Jane
and Mr. Hirad Dinavari
that very warmly supported
and received the suggestion
so that we can have this.
I will very briefly talk a
little bit about how we came
out to make this documentary.
The documentary itself goes
through the history and how this,
my father was interested and how the
children literature was developed
in Iran, which my father played
a very major role in that.
But to make it short, I, as a
child, was very fond of my father.
So I used to listen to him a lot and
he would tell me about his childhood
and his interests and very
difficult childhood that he had
and you'll see in the film.
And I learned a lot about his life
and his education and how he came
to become interested in children's
literature and got involved
in writing and magazines and so on.
At the same time I was also a
subject of what he was doing.
I was audience as well
because I was right
at the age that he was writing for.
So when the Kayhan Bacheha,
which everybody knows here,
when it came out, started, my
father started with another
of his colleagues, I
started reading that.
I read the first textbook
that was written by my father
as a national textbook
for the first graders.
So I read that and so
on until I read it --
So I became very familiar
with the poetry in his works
and how he developed and all
the chronology of it as well.
Then as I grew up and I went
to high school and I realized
that his fame is just growing
in Iran and everybody knew him,
which was kind of natural to me, but
then after I came to United States
as a student, went
back, worked there,
and I saw that this has
become a more than normal.
He had -- Because of generation
that read the textbooks and went
to school that he established
with my mother and all the books
and different things and magazines,
so and that became very interesting
for me because that there
was somebody that started
from even not zero, negative,
as you will see in this film,
with no support, not only no
support but all the hurdles
that you can think of
in front of somebody,
going back about 80
years ago in Iran
when children were really not
even counted as human beings.
They were just in a transition
period, a waiting period to grow up.
That's all it was, to grow up
and just take some burden off
the shoulders of the parents.
So it was very interesting that
that person, without any support,
could come and become somebody who
could really play this major role
in the children's literature
and became very famous.
So that by itself was
very interesting.
And Iran is a difficult
environment for the people
that they don't have any support.
So you have somebody that can come
up with this very interesting story,
that's why I thought I would
like to make that documentary
and then we thought about it.
The environment in Iran
at that time was not --
But recently, because
documentaries are very popular,
it became easier to make it.
So and at the same time,
Children's Book Council
of Iran a few years ago
had a tribute to my father
and that also was very interesting.
From that tribute came
a major article
in Iranian newspaper [inaudible]
and the person who wrote
that article was the person who
later on became the director
of the film, Mr. Hooman Zarif.
And he actually called me a few
years after we had that tribute
and now I'm thinking for years
to make this documentary.
He called me and said, "I want
to make a documentary
about your father."
And I said.
"That's pretty good."
And he wanted me to support.
I said, "Well, you have full
support but what do you know
about documentary,
you're a journalist?"
He said he just made a documentary
about another person who was known
to Iran, Hossein Gol-e-Golab,
and who was a lyric and composer
and he has made that
famous national anthem
of Iran, the people, [inaudible].
So I went to Iran.
We looked at it and he
said that was possible.
The time was good to make it
and it was pretty much
the last window we had
because all the characters
that you see in this film,
the major characters in
the Book Council of Iran,
Children's Book Council,
they were at the age
that they probably
could not do it anymore.
You will see [inaudible],
Parviz Kalantari,
which is a famous illustrator,
book illustrator in Iran.
He is now in coma and still lives
for over a year, except a couple
of other characters,
they just passed away.
My mother is not in
state to participate.
So that's all.
It was very opportune time and
we managed to make this film
and well we hope you enjoy it as
much as I did in producing it.
Thanks so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Hirad Dinavari: A quick book
essentially notes for the end.
We have little surveys
on your chairs.
Feel free to fill them
out after the film.
We would love to hear your opinion
and know what you think
about the movie.
I'm about to start the film.
After the movie, we will have a few
minutes for questions from Homan,
which I'm very grateful for him and
his family for coming all the way
from California for this.
And at that point we
look forward answering
to any questions you
may have for him.
Let's start the film.
Thank you.
I would like to everyone
for staying.
I know it's a little --
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
I realize it's a little over an
hour but the film was worth it.
I am so grateful to Mr. Homan
Yamini Sharif for being here
and their lovely family for coming
all the way from California.
Our film crew has another
event to film at 2 o'clock.
So we really don't
have that much time.
But I would like to give a few
minutes for questions for Homan,
if you would come up here,
and take a few questions.
We really need to wrap it up
within three to four minutes.
Thank you.
Any questions, feel
free to get up and ask.
>> This question [inaudible].
It would seem to me that
the foundation has been laid
for international children's
literature.
I'm overwhelmed.
I'm so very, very moved by what I've
seen and learned, and yet I can feel
that it's this universal
[inaudible],
it's all of the children everywhere.
>> Homan Yamini Sharif: Exactly.
Well, I think there are two
probably periods in our life
that this [inaudible] really becomes
meaningful as a child and then
at the end of life, that
wholeness comes back to us.
So it is pretty much the same
concept and same stories here
as probably has been in one way
or another has been repeated
in other nations and they came of
people from different period of time
when children were not
really paid attention to
and they started writing and
bringing a new world to children.
>> Hirad Dinavari:
Any other questions?
No? All right.
>> Can you just tell us how long
it took to put the film together?
>> Homan Yamini Sharif:
Well, it took about two years
and the reason it took this long was
it had to be done during the trips
to Iran and getting all these people
together and finding time for them,
the different conditions they
were enduring took some time.
Also, it was difficult to edit and
I had to be present for the edition,
because for the chronology
and all different relative
subjects had to be taken care of.
We also we wanted to do more filming
but the conditions in Iran were
in such a way that if you wanted to
film, you know, in public places,
you had to go through certain
getting permission and all that
and we did not really have the
time to do it and so we had to come
with different creativity
to do this.
>> I have a question.
>> Go ahead.
>> Just a brief one.
When you are filming,
you are talking,
you're in a beautiful
environment outside with the trees
and then it rains, where
was it [inaudible]?
>> Homan Yamini Sharif:
It was a house that was --
Ironically, it was very interesting,
the [inaudible] in Iran,
the television, radio
and television,
approached us when they heard that
we are filming this and they wanted
to get the license to make the film.
But because they would make it the
way they wanted, I said, "Well,
let me make it and then if you like
it, then we'll, you can use that."
But they helped us and
said, "How can we help you?"
It was very interesting
to have that cooperation.
And one of the things they did
is they have different contracts
with different places.
When they want to film,
they can go there.
They said, "What do you need?"
I said, "We'd like to be in
an environment which looks
like my father's childhood."
So they arranged this.
This is a village north of
Tehran, in [inaudible] area.
So we went there and
we did the film.
>> So my question is for the footage
for the film, all the photographs
and items, did you get
most of it from inside Iran
or did you look elsewhere as well
and how much archives are there
from people you interviewed
that they gave you
or sharing their [inaudible]
with you?
>> Homan Yamini Sharif: The
archives, all the documents
and other film, pictures
and reviews and all
that came from our own archives.
My father had a very good archive
while he was alive collecting
different books and magazine,
literature and his own books
and we preserved that and we kept it
and we collected as
much as we could.
So we have archives in the
Foundation and we used this.
>> That's wonderful.
>> And who is illustrator?
Did you father paint or your sister?
>> Homan Yamini Sharif:
The illustrator that talked
in the film was Parviz Kalantari.
Parviz Kalantari is a well known
illustrator for children's books
and he was also a close
friend of my father
and illustrated several
books for him.
He has won several
international awards for his work.
And as I mentioned, it's one of the
unfortunate things that happened
that he had a illness
that took him to coma
and he's still in coma in Iran.
>> Hirad Dinavari: Okay,
thank you very much, everyone.
Thanks --
>> Homan Yamini Sharif: Thank
you very much for coming.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.